julia helicóptero militar regresa de una
operación de rescate en el valle de
calama ya que todas las carreteras que
conducen a las zonas han sido arrasadas
por las feroces inundaciones entre los
rescatados hay algunos turistas varados
pero también lugareños heridos este
hombre lleva a su hijo herido en la
espalda
esta mujer embarazada lleva días enferma
la llevan directamente a un hospital
la ciudad estuvo completamente sumergida
bajo el agua hasta hace 12 días pero
ahora el agua está retrocediendo
lentamente al ajax a un trabajador de la
construcción ha vuelto a su casa para
hacerse una idea de los daños que se han
producido por las inundaciones lo han
destruido todo el agua ha subido hasta
aquí todo este muro se ha agrietado
veanlo con sus propios ojos ven te
mostraré cómo está el interior mira aquí
el suelo se ha derrumbado y
tardaremos al menos seis meses en
reconstruir nuestra casa el gobierno
solo ha prometido cien dólares no es
suficiente es como dar un grano de arroz
a un hambriento
los que aún no pueden volver a sus casas
se ven obligados a vivir en campamentos
improvisados como este algunas ongs
locales intentan distribuir productos de
ayuda pero a menudo acaban en caos
los jóvenes y las personas fuertes son
capaces de abrirse camino mientras que
las mujeres y los ancianos tienen
dificultades
hay mucha gente hay muchas personas sin
mover en cuanto llega una furgoneta con
ayuda humanitaria la gente se reúne a su
alrededor
[Aplausos]
hay escasez de alimentos refugios
medicamentos para niños y leche para los
recién nacidos la situación es la misma
en todos lados
tengo mucha hambre no he comido nada
desde esta mañana pensé que al menos
podría consumir un paquete de galletas
pero solo hay hombres y nos empujan
tengo seis hijas y un hijo pequeño nos
obligan a vivir en estas condiciones
humillantes
la mayoría de las familias aquí
pertenecen al sector más pobre de la
sociedad han perdido la mayoría sus
pertenencias sus casas han quedado
destruidas o muy dañadas no saben si
podrán volver a su vida anterior